famously Greenland was settled by the
Vikings and I just ran into the first
guy here who looks like a Viking Nicky
you look like a Viking you also look
like a cleanup hitter for the Boston Red
Sox you can buy a gun here but there's
no gun violence here no no we know how
to use weight you want for three days
what are you Johnny Appleseed what do
you do well you don't need to it's a
very funny reference and people in my
country we laugh and keep one your
country won't see this here's the point
you want for three days why
so next time you go for a walk for three
days you think oh sure I come do we
bring any food with us and just eat it
raw
on the side of the road have you eaten a
rod dear you ate a raw liver
well yeah you're not an animal this is
incredible you are you have true Viking
blood oh you think I would pass for
Viking you think I've seen manly enough
to be a Viking now why fix something
what do you mean soon after my arrival I
was interviewed by knr Greenland's
biggest and only television station
Emily commute Eva coupeau yes I was a
token and O'Brien suppose I could not
the Thule an eternity nipple America me
president yet I know not put speciality
Kesari some ago is he not on another
your sock by donald trump's in eternity
not is Martin in yesterday Conan O'Brien
Cohen L amid not be Papa said of Conan
O'Brien by how are you how are you I'm
good I was just wandering in these rocks
yeah he's only beautiful beautiful on I
saw you doing a story and I thought I'd
come over Conan O'Brien no muchísimo
mama chicken pock garage ik noona taro
PC Iranian national issue McCutcheon in
the area personnel but what is your
interest of Kremlin but it felt like a
really fun opportunity to come here and
meet everybody and if I come here as
part of my show I don't have to pay for
it okay so this is a free trip for me
Pacifica that we saw book billion Tata
City Topanga we swore to get another
book
cassadee only me the first time for
yourself for that much
Donald Trump is you know put PC ELISA
guru nuke unit in yes-mo today sir she
was about that Kuya sounds up to put her
in either the golf course you have a
golf course it's called the golf club
leukemic tahoe didn't make the meaning
of it's hard to say I mean I've been
inspired by so many people the Kellogg
family I think it's name is William
Kellogg you know he was the first person
to make breakfast cereal
I had not a always happy childhood and
one of the things I took solace in was
sugar cereals your Cocoa Krispies your
Captain Crunch your Captain Crunch with
crunch berries a cocoa puffs anything
with chocolate in it and marshmallows
Lucky Charms
Kellogg's Italy so they actually came to
my childhood and they're one of the
reasons today but I can't lift things
above my shoulder yeah so the potato
cores are a good career not Doty Titanic
miss addictive the next stop on my
Greenland press tour was an interview
and photo shoot with the CEO of
Greenland's biggest and only airline
Jacob thank you for having me to your
wonderful country thank you for coming
here I very much enjoy your airline it's
long been my dream to be in an in-flight
magazine yeah I always wanted to be in
an in-flight magazine and I've tried and
tried and tried got very close with
Virgin Atlantic once and then they find
out that I was a virgin
they thought I was a bad publicity
what's been your impression of Greenland
and the grinning people this is a
stunning country absolutely beautiful
also and I'm gonna go out on a limb here
but I'm gonna say that no country I've
ever been to has better
fried fish you guys kill it with dried
fish I don't know what you do but no one
drives a fish like you guys and what a
great way to experience fish yeah you
know you can keep the fish in your
wallets you can kick me in a panic you
can use the dried pressed fish as a
bookmark and then when you're done with
people you can eat the bookmark the fish
it's amazing I see people walking around
they trade them like old baseball cards
I don't know who's out there with a blow
dryer on the beach excellent Thank You
Conan and before I knew it I was back at
Kay on our studios to lend a little star
power to their nightly broadcast please
keep in mind this really aired all
across Greenland commutes ever almost a
mummy or no good off enough master nope
I know Kaka so it's honest yours is a
good evening in the Greenlandic language
let's face it how hard could it be a
Pabu are finan Gangaram be so a summary
of a master attack atella Peretz is
seeking a Larry see you Olga Farney a
sibling
sumit illa my sweet Queen
[Applause]
just cold stuff coming
you